I'm here with Travis Hume who is the
creator of the applying stoicism project
something I think is particularly
interesting for modern stoic
applications for what's going on in the
whole modern stoic movement
I'll let Travis tell you about it in
just a minute but first I'm going to
tell you a little bit about how I got to
know him and about with what I
understand his project to be and why I
think it's particularly cool so I'll
start with that
the the applying stoicism is unlike some
other projects that you can see it out
there people are talking about stoicism
in that Travis only writes about things
where he's actually given it a shot
doesn't mean that he necessarily
succeeded in it but a lot of the time he
does but but things that that he has
actually applied in his real-life career
relationships and that reflected about
so I think that's that's a really great
project you can find him we'll talk
about this at the end as well because
you can find him not only on the you
know main web page but also there's a
Facebook group there's a Google+ he's on
patreon if you'd like to support his
activity that's which I strongly suggest
you doing because it's a great project
so how did you actually decide to do
this in the first place it was an
extension of me trying to help other
people and where I was at so in my
second year of college I discovered
stoicism to give you a shorthand version
of it I I was extremely emotional I was
constantly worried about what other
people were thinking about me what
people were saying about me I was in
state where I felt as though if I wasn't
in a relationship that it somehow
impacted my value as a person and during
an intro to philosophy course that I was
forced to take high by my chosen major
psychology major I overheard some things
from somebody that called Epictetus that
really clicked with me
and from that point on I thought to
myself is there different approach to
life is it possible that what Epictetus
said which was it's enough to be a good
person to be happy
could that really be true and I started
I took a shot in the dark and I started
trying to really put into practice what
he said so for you it was an
experimental introduction you could say
oh yeah it was it was highly
experimental I had no idea what I was
doing to be to be perfectly honest I had
no idea that was going to have any kind
of really lasting psychological effects
I knew that other people we're going to
see my change of behavior I started to
question it possibly stopping friends
with me I really had no idea what what
kind of impact it was going to have
humming in general as I started
practicing it I started to see that
there was a real behavioral difference
things started to get to me lesser to be
impacted less and as a result of the
different incentives the different
suggestions that the Stoics suggests in
order to try to help those around us and
our grater or media community I tried to
latch on to that and start acting upon
that so I joined student government I
became a resident assistant at my
university and I started a Facebook
group which is now forms the core of
most of my writing aside from putting
the rest of it onto my main website it
started as just something that was for
my friends and family saying to them
that they understood that I was
something called a stoic and then it
affected my behavior somehow but it was
a way for other people to for one to get
a better understanding of why I went
about things the way that I did and at
the same time potentially trying to help
them see how I apply stoicism and to try
to factor it into their own lives I
didn't do any kind of marketing I didn't
I didn't try to put out there that this
website existed because I really tightly
controlled my expectations of what it
was or what it could be
so most of the vast majority of the
growth that is experienced has
from word-of-mouth and I'm very happy
with that yeah that's actually one of
the things I mean this is a bigger topic
for like the whole modern story
community I think there's there's some
sort of using the the stoic name or the
stoic idea to sell something and there's
more of an emphasis on like let's do the
market research beforehand and does the
dichotomy of control sell well you know
let's let's talk about yeah with you
it's the exact opposite where you're
doing it first and that if people come
to it that that's great the Facebook
group interestingly I should point out
has sort of taken on a life of its own
where a lot of people are posting their
own applied stoicism stuff I post there
as well when I when I do a video that
might be relevant to a blog post and so
if I think actually on Facebook in the
modern stoic moment it's probably the
second largest of the Facebook groups
you know behind the main one that Donald
Robertson runs which nothing can really
compare with that that's got 35,000
members it's not 35 but I think you guys
you have three or four thousand members
at this time so that's you know pretty
pretty amazing yeah I know you have more
members on your Facebook group that I
have on my author page that I've had out
for about six years so I think you've
been building a community yes so
originally it's the way that you
approach that is the same that then I've
been approaching it to now which is if I
experienced anything or I'm going to go
into some kind of event or I'm
anticipating it how do i how do I take
what I'm experiencing and applying
solecism to it and to try to convert it
into something that other people can
read and ultimately use and I haven't
ever deviated from that I'm never going
to deviate from that but in the in the
time that it's it's been growing I've
noticed that other people are starting
to contribute kind of in the same way
and then ultimately now they are
contributing in that same way where
they're posting their
their essays yeah they're their personal
projects and I'm very appreciative of
that
for me personally what matters to me the
most is that people are ultimately
benefited by this and they're able to
take what they see on there and are able
to apply it to their own lives and be
benefited from it because the more that
it circulates the the more that it could
potentially benefit other people and
that's that's ultimately what my goal is
as well as long as what's on there is
constructive and assist people in their
personal practice that's that's the game
so I'm very happy with this that so it
brings up a good question
I think for some of the viewers who
might not be as familiar with stoic
philosophy I think a lot of people view
it as in terms of self-help is kind of
withdrawal from things that we find
irritating or anxiety provoking so that
you know we insulate ourselves from
effectively from the world and from from
other people but the way that you're
talking about it when you mentioned once
you started doing this you got into
student government I think a lot of
people but why would you possibly do
that right or this this notion of you
know creating a website which is a big
hassle that quite frankly monotreme yeah
but what people forget in the
conversations they get into to help
other people so why is that particularly
stoic so for most people in my very
personal opinion they're going to be
going into it kind of the way that that
you just described which they're looking
for some kind of greater internal
freedom against all the kinds of things
that that life throws at us seemingly on
it moment to moment basis sometimes and
and it was it was the same for me I
approached Sosa's like I said because I
wanted to have that sort of control
that's sort of insulation some kind of a
greater range of agency or action or at
least at least a feeling representative
of it that's that's how I see a lot of a
lot of people approach it and and in the
beginning that's it might might have
been in okay it's okay to feel that way
because it has there has to be a
starting point somewhere and you have to
be able to focus
most of your effort into into one thing
at a time especially when it relates to
yeah so a clause and you know just to
interject I think a lot of people when
they hear that stoic philosophy has a
social component or you know the justice
matters if they haven't got that sort of
foundation laid and they jump right into
that then you know they're already a
mess over here and how they get to be a
mess okay right Alex fear yeah it
doesn't work out well for anyone yeah
but the the mistake that I sometimes see
is that that's where the line is drawn
is saying what what I am what am i doing
for me in order to help me out
and then they kind of latch overly much
on to the concept of what's in our
control versus what's not and they
mistakenly from from what I believe
apply that to other people or to other
spheres they think that that's the line
so you don't cross it and they focus
most of their effort on that what what
it appears to me is that you cannot
escape that that community aspect of
Stoicism
it's it's ingrained into it so I'm a
little bit touch-and-go not not quite
fully comfortable when it comes to the
Greek terms or the Latin terms
many of them have connotations or they
mean several words or sentiments
simultaneously so that's something that
I need to personally improve on but
there's there's certain words like okay
okey OSIS oh yeah like you know is is
that correct me if I'm wrong but that's
that's this idea that every individual
or being is looking out for their
self-interest in some respect yeah well
I started yes and so how do we so most
people would think okay well that just
means me but when it comes when you
involve the other aspects of like the
stoic web-like structure of the
philosophy which is which is how I
describe it yeah
as it happens what's in my self-interest
as a social and rational animal designed
by whatever powers that be it means that
by helping
the greater community or those that are
nearest to me at the same time that I'm
self-improving
it's it's mutual it's not mutually
exclusive you by helping other people
you are helping yourself and that's why
different Stoics like Cato the younger
became so ingrained and in Roman
politics or treated the soldiers that
that were unrepentant to the day extent
that he did by showing that he wasn't
above them he was with them that it was
only a title difference
yes he did and and Marcus releases
meditations he's constantly telling
himself not to be just be another Caesar
and that he was that he was put in this
position by whatever combination of
elements or events to assist those that
he happens to be in a position above for
like over over way of a better way of
putting it so you you can't dissect
those that you eventually and in my
personal experience and from what I've
seen you you will develop an
understanding that in order to assist
yourself there has to be there has to be
a way that you help other people at the
same time yeah you know it's um they
frame it sort of as rational animals and
as animals we have this natural you know
self-preservation drive and that the
question is what are we what do we sort
of extend ourselves to or identify
ourselves with it's you know here at
least has this nice circles metaphor
that gets talked about quite a bit we
serve their family and now of course
this presupposes oh they actually like
our family which isn't the case for
everybody but you know you get the idea
there's a natural affection there and
you know when when you think about your
family members you don't actually do
like some sort of you know very egoistic
calculation like well if I'm nice to
them it's gonna pay off right right like
a transactional said you're like look at
my you know my brothers is in pain I'm
gonna go
you know deal with it because it also
makes me feel bad that he is or I can
celebrate with them or I'm gonna do what
conduces so then we expanded outward and
we use that as here Klee says these
circles that eventually extended the
whole world
I think they saw that it's it's a
natural thing provided we get the
obstacles out of the way yeah our own
selfishness or fears or our you know
willingness to sort of cut people off so
it's not natural like we will
automatically do it like a plant right
you know yeah so there's there's a
couple of different things that I can
say about that for for one they're in in
terms of our self-interest or
self-preservation instincts there's a
clear distinction between what is
beneficial to to me as just a physical
living entity and that I need food
shelter some kind of reasonable
temperature nothing too cold nothing too
hot but like preferably somewhere in the
middle or if it's good to be like that
some clothes yes yeah clothes clothes if
you can you can balance it out a little
bit that way those those definitely help
but the the distinction comes when you
look at people as in terms of what I
described which was that their social
and rational so there's there's a tear
that's above just us being animals and
reacting to these these impulses that I
need to eat I need to sleep I need to do
all the other very pleasant things that
that are a part of me as just a living
being but that because of this extra
tear you need to consider how to help
yourself as as of being that that has
reason that is part of a community so
the way that I've always phrased it to
myself in order to help reaffirm that as
many times is that it needs to be
reaffirmed is that we as human beings
can tell that we have to depend or
understand on this the social rational
aspects of ourselves because
of how we've been able to survive dummy
most of the Plano that that is is that
we don't have poison
we don't have claws we don't have wings
the the strongest among us are probably
never going to be able to compete
reasonably with a bear and tourism rely
right in terms of sheer strength and and
you you kind of get my point when it
when it comes to that so what do we have
I mean we are our greatest you know
physical evolutionary defense is that we
havin to smell really bad if left alone
for a long time without without bathing
but that's big brains yeah that's that's
creative yeah so you also have the big
brains and that's that's where that's
where the social rational elements come
into that we are again designed to use
that word loosely by whatever powers
that be to use that term loosely to work
together to communicate to coordinate so
if we ignore that aspect of ourselves
and just say you know screw you got mine
that's sort of that sort of mentality we
are actually acting in the face of that
nature if we and so we become
animal-like to an extent when we behave
that way but we become even more so
because we give away or act in the face
of this this primary advantage that
we've had this this thing that defines
us as human beings and epictetus talks
about that he says you you will never be
faster than a horse or is it more
handsome than a horse yeah I'm gonna
live to be both and and he says you you
will never be able to fly like a bird
and so on and so that's that's where I
draw most of that idea from is that I am
I am more than just body I'm more than
just something that has to eat or sleep
so what defines me and I need to improve
that part of myself by improving that
part of myself and acting always in
light of that then it gets me closer to
what is most excellent for me to use
enough uses terms which is what brings
you closer as a person as a stoic to the
concept of eudaimonia which is like
personal excellence there's there's all
sorts of other meetings meanings
floating around that not just excellence
but that's the general term you know
it's as if stoicism and other virtue
ethics that have similar what we can
call teleological is sort of goal
oriented or oriented views on human
nature are saying that human nature
isn't something that we can simply take
for granted it's something that has to
be a project for us to develop within
ourselves and I was thinking as you're
talking about this you know the Stoics
are actually the beginners of the
natural law tradition that we see
running through the Middle Ages and that
you know playing some role in modern
theory and we've got this basic level of
the self-preservation
all the animals share that in common
some of them don't do a very good job at
it but you know all right let me try
yeah and then before we actually get to
like the distinctively human the other
thing that that like Cicero talks about
was echoing this stoic philosopher named
Diaz he's basically sort of transcribing
penaity essence ethics and adding a few
wrinkles of his own is that there's also
the level of sexual desire and care for
offspring and then then he talks about
the rational level now you know it's
interesting as rational creatures these
other lower drives get possibly
transformed so that you know we are we
are a species that does couple right you
know some people are attracted in
different ways but you know that still
sort of heteronormative at this time
where a male and a female you know get
together now we may be doing serial
monogamy or some people are into all
sorts of things but there is a basic
thing there and how is that rationally
transformed this is something that
Stokes don't talk that much about I
think imperfect is ancient culture they
just took a lot of this for granted
right but I think this is incredibly
important for our own day you mentioned
like you know the feeling of
not in a relationship what the hell are
you doing you know what's your life
worth I think this is something a lot of
people struggle with not just you know
be in a relationship but what kind of
relationship and so do you think
stoicism has much to contribute on yes
yes absolutely
so I think that some of that might be
cultural I think that it's it's deeper
than that kind of in the way that you
described and that's almost like things
and to use the term like an instinctual
type drive to seek something else out
just somebody that matches well with us
it's it's part of that underlying drive
so to speak so to give you a specific
example of what I believe that you're
referring to early on and in my practice
I'd say about like a year or so after I
started trying to randomly apply this
stuff where I could try to retain even
simple statements and then trying to
figure out where they apply and and so
on and so forth let's we should talk
about that a little bit that's yes that
practice of using stoic dog motto yeah
little sayings you know every one of the
Stoics says you've got a stock up your
head with with these one-liners actually
because you're gonna need it
yeah and I'll segue into that so the
early on I eventually I said until you
feel as though you you have a grasp of
how you interact with other people and
how well I want you I'm saying this to
myself that's why I'm phrasing it that
way I want you to go on dates as long as
you are constantly reminding yourself
that you aren't going into the date with
the ultimate objective in order to form
a relationship or to to sleep with them
or to gain something through them if you
feel as though as though you are
behaving in that way then I want you to
restrict yourself because it's only
permissible as long as you are spending
time as one human being to another human
being and want a began thinking in terms
like that all the pressure that I was
putting on myself faded and ultimately
it was control
and reined in and curtail that make the
experience butter yes it absolutely did
it because I was focus focus on what the
person was saying well that is were what
what their hobbies were and serve while
she's she's really pretty or or any of
the other thoughts that that segue from
that yeah and first of all the meetings
were actually way more comfortable as it
happens
most people are attuned to an extent of
how comfortable the other person is or
if they're putting on airs or something
like that and so it seemed to me that
other people were or more comfortable
with me as I was behaving this way so
that's that is to answer kind of the
question that can have before the or the
point or the suggestion as for how it
affects I believe that your question was
how it affects like your approach other
people generally or well I mean we could
talk about that I mean I wasn't actually
thinking about that whole realm of okay
yeah relationships sexual desire I mean
III I'm not so concerned here about the
child-rearing part which which is
interesting but you know for you that's
going to happen later I think I don't
for me I've got kids and I do see a lot
of applications for stoicism with that
and as I've been writing on that I've
noticed that the Stoics actually don't
tell us that much yeah or about
relationships but this is a big field
that I think for modern stoicism
somebody could write you know stoicism
in dating book and I think it wouldn't
make sense to do so right now I agree
with that
like Donald Roberson has mentioned the
past which is kind of a phrasing or
something that I've kept in mind is that
99% of all stoic material has been lost
including that's right flaws percent and
they did in fact it's either zina or
course impass wrote an art of love yeah
yeah so there were some books on
marriage and things like that so they
did talk about it you know just we just
don't have it so would you would you
like me to discuss some of the phrasing
or the terms of things that you say
kind of that's a good idea moved away
from that yeah so to give you some
background I didn't go into this just
knowing what to do or how to do or how
to approach it
so I'll tell you an interesting very
shorthand story I thought that Epictetus
was the guy that came up was so assume
as it turns out it was it was not so I
was reading from this interval ASCII
book where it had a very very short
synopsis of the history of it for as far
as I was concerned it was Xena Xena was
involved somehow somebody named Zeno but
didn't really touch on who he was or how
he was important not that he was a
founder of like still a system or
anything because I guess that that was
kind of like an aside point well really
what a philosophy textbooks are a whole
different you know yeah thing that we
could get up bothers soapbox yeah but I
thought that Z know what just buddied up
with with Epictetus at some point and
there's a simple baby right then that
they both worked with it I thought that
Epicurus who was in the following
chapter was some kind of pen name or
ghostwriter for epictetus but I always
and that's and that's something that's
something else so the only material that
I had for about a year was Epictetus is
in Cairo right now and if you're not
familiar with what the enchiridion is
it's a handbook version a pamphlet
almost of phrasings or sayings that you
would carry around with you in in a
pocket I don't know togas yes men really
in the handbook you know yeah and keiter
idiom means little yeah and it was a
compilation of the discourses this
courses came in several books and I'll
recall ultimately how many but of the
surviving ones I think that there's four
and we afford we think there might have
been eight
yeah so I I was drawing most of my my
experience my means of application from
this handbook and hopefully the handbook
was seemingly designed around the idea
that they were reminders they were short
curt to the point kind of self-contained
ideas that you would be able to apply on
the go
hence the handbook nature of it but I
with it because it was difficult for me
to
and of going into it from the outside
how and where they applied I was
guessing so what I did was I looked at a
statement and I tried to think of where
that would apply
what kind of common daily situations I
would come across in which I could use
this and then my goal was to remember
that it exists and what the words were
and then tried to apply it to that
specific situation what was most helpful
to me in the beginning was the idea that
your favorite thing breaks just because
of its nature as a physical wall two
three right as a physical object fragile
things break if you kind of lose sight
of that fact and you say my favorite
thing broke and this is bad
then you're necessarily going to feel
everything that accompanies the thought
this thing that I liked is broken and
this is bad because it won't be able to
use anymore so now the world sucks yeah
exactly
so this applies not just to the fragile
thing that he was talking about I think
was a vase but it applied to my coffee
cup Mike my favorite coffee cup which
had like my like a little quote on it
that I personally enjoyed as it related
to a video game that broke twice and
each time I thought to myself there's
something that I'm remembering
the enchiridion that applies to this so
I would go back and try to find it and
do to the handbook nature it's
relatively simple to do so I would read
it and I would say how many other cups
do I have to drink out of it wasn't just
this one yeah is there anything in this
situation that prevents me from going
out and getting another one if I really
felt as though I was going to to miss it
to that extent then eventually as I
started thinking in terms like that as
it relates to things that are lost it
extended outward there was a situation
in which I had an opportunity to buy a
laptop I wasn't really financially
I wasn't financially comfortable but the
alternative was that I had no computer
to work with and there was an increasing
emphasis on relying on computers on
online discussion boards so on and so
forth so what I was doing was that
during my time as a Resident Assistant I
would Tran I would put down on pen and
paper entire essays that I was supposed
to eventually upload so in a sense I was
doing twice the work it made sense to me
given this temporary financial increase
that I had at one point from working a
job to buy a laptop and this was really
going to be the only opportunity to do
so so I went out and bought a laptop
I got a mid-range one I didn't I wanted
something that I wasn't going to have to
really worry about for a long time or
about it's slowing down kind of on its
own as some of the cheaper laptops do
and I had it for about a week so I went
to lunch and in the cafeteria there are
these cubby holes everybody puts their
backpacks in them and they go out into
the into the country because the idea is
that if you bring your backpack
into the cafeteria you might try to
sneak like food or or other items into
it like a hundred ketchup packets or
something like that and they want to
keep all their ketchup packets inside
understandably they have their
priorities yeah correct so I left my
laptop I was taken to a class and I went
into the one of the cafeteria when it
came out my backpack was missing
completely and I had no idea where it
was so I said to myself right we're
almost right away so in the beginning
when you're still practicing you're
going to feel all these sentiments just
because you read a paragraph and are
trying to apply it it doesn't mean that
you're going to feel all the effects or
that you're going to believe it once you
start yes once you start realizing that
it actually has an effect however
gradual on your behavior you start to to
understand how a factors end and when a
factors them into what extent but at
this moment I said you you're feeling as
though this is this is a terrible thing
this was a very expensive item that you
just purchased and and what does what
does not it not being here mean of
course I did all the conventional things
I asked
I talked to the captain ladies and and
guys and seeing if they they had seen
where it went
nobody saw anything okay my second step
was was there some kind of security
footage and that is being recorded over
these cubby holes would you imagine that
there would be as it turns out there
wasn't yeah and asking people nearby but
I understood that as time went on the
lower the chance that I would actually
find this thing so as I was heading to
campus police I was saying to myself
this is exactly the type of situation
that you're not going to have a second
opportunity to react properly to what
does it mean to not have this fancy new
laptop that that you've had it just
means that you're going to go have to go
back to writing a paper there was a time
when you didn't have a laptop and
although it wasn't convenient you are
fine this is just a shift this is you
just not having it anymore don't and and
then I have to remind myself of what the
person that that thought to take it was
feeling as far as they were concerned
they were they were doing something that
was appropriate to them it doesn't
necessarily make it okay yeah it doesn't
but they were driven by this feeling
that perhaps they didn't have a laptop
and so they thought that it was in their
best interest to take it from another
person regardless of whether or not that
was harming again their their nature as
social and rational animals it's
impossible for them to have behaved in a
different way the only way that I can
show other people that isn't appropriate
to take it as by modeling my behavior
after that it's possible that it's
unlikely but possible that during my
interactions with other people in which
this topic happens to be discussed that
that person might be listening or
thinking about about the situation so I
went to campus police as it turns out
all the preparations I did just in case
this sort of thing happened the serial
numbers the date those purchased the the
receipt it didn't pan out I got one
question from them saying do you
remember if you had a Wi-Fi on or
something like that and
and they never found it that said the
the following day I was passing by in
the cafeteria and I saw my backpack in
the garbage so whoever it was that took
the laptop threw away the the backpack
why they didn't just put it in the cubby
hole I couldn't tell you maybe they were
trying to hide the evidence I don't know
but everything everything that was in
there the only thing that was that was
missing was the laptop itself so they
didn't take any of the books and that
was enough museum value right and and
that was an opportunity as potentially
odd as it sounds to be appreciative of
the fact that I had a backpack first of
all because I was mentally preparing
myself to carry all my stuff in plastic
bags and that all my books were there
including some of the philosophy books
that I then it started immediately using
right afterward so that's that's just a
description of of how I've I've applied
these different statements so the the
statements are something that you that
you try to use on hand it's very
difficult to segue from reading
something to trying to purposely retain
it to understanding the context in which
those statements apply and then to to be
able to apply it reliably yeah what
helps is to as the situation is
happening is to call to mind those
statements as forcefully as you can and
to remember the entirety to the extent
as as you can and then following it and
kind of the way that I suggested yeah
each of the historical authors that we
have stresses how important that is you
know is looking today is beginning
stoical week in the morning reading is
one that we've passed through many times
and Marcus really talking about the
inner Synod oh you know create one for
you know refuge for yourself and it's it
says at the very end of that the thing
this is the way you're going to do it
stock up these these you know these
statements for yourself because it's not
an inner-city retreat into yourself and
you know
like in the Seinfeld episode say
serenity now it's here itself right yeah
instead you if they have it's almost you
know wait I think we say you know good
the best defense is a good offense
handing those things ready at hand it's
not like you're fighting the world or
anything like that rather you're ready
to respond to the situations because
you've there's another word that the
Stoics use a lot you prepared yourself
in great parts of scouting and you know
literally means to like have all your
stuff laid out around you all your [ __ ]
is almost like a shot yeah when a
mechanic lays out their tools or a chef
is doing their meson floss that's
exactly what what that sort of thing so
there's there's a couple of quotes that
come to mind again I'm paraphrasing but
Marcus really is specifically reference
is something like that and that you
don't want to be like a gladiator per se
or you need to pick up a sword in order
to have a fight properly but you want to
be a boxer instead where all you have to
do is just use what you've already got
in order to face the world Seneca
mentions variously somewhere and and the
letters that's you if what what you are
doing by trying to consider things in
terms of what could happen and what your
responses to them would be and what's
happening in front of you and reacting
to it properly as as a soldier that's
just preparing themselves so he he makes
reference to the Roman soldier practice
of putting up ramparts making sure that
all of your arms and armor are organized
properly yeah that you are doing drills
even if nothing is necessarily happening
so that when the when the enemy Church
does come that you're in a position
where you're already prepared to say
I've done all my stuff now I just need
to use what's in front of me Epictetus
also mentions times where you are faced
with something and are in a position
where you must respond to it in some
sense as this being the trial or the
competition or the Olympics or how you
want to use it
there's a tendency to say well to say to
yourself I just want to keep practicing
I just want to I'm not writing it I want
to I want to keep preparing and and it's
it's not gonna be allowed it has to be
now
and he makes reference to that by saying
that somebody that is preparing to
wrestle doesn't say to themselves at the
at the moment of the competition I wish
that I could go back to my room and I've
started doing other thing wait still in
preparation for this they just do it so
we have to have the same mentality as
practicing so it's and you also when
you're wrestling you can't say your
opponent I need you to I what I've
practiced is this could you like put
your arm in that position would you just
do that for me like real quick like let
me just kind of do what I've said that I
could do but yeah there's there's
seemingly endless opportunities to get
that that level of practice yeah and
then the more that we do it the better
you know like anything else the better
we get at it but we're never you know
totally prepared for everything that
comes across our plate because the world
is very complex right he's always
throwing us new stuff so there was there
was something that that may be
interesting to those watching that kind
of phrasing that I suggested to myself
very early on in my practice is that
personally I refuse to call myself a day
stoic like with a capital s stoic I
always called myself a practicing stoic
and the reason why I specifically frame
things that way to myself was because I
I wanted to say that until I have a feel
like I have a hold on particularly
difficult events I I want to be in this
frame of mind where I don't just assume
that I know how to react to these
different things because if I assume
that I know it's going to potentially
affect my behavior in the way that I
talk to all the people that are still
learning if I assume that I know and act
as though I know and and stay to other
person's or recommend courses of actions
to other persons
that you should do this in this kind of
situation and it could they could try to
use it and potentially they might do it
correctly because I suggested it
incorrectly and then they're going to be
the ones that are in a sense harmed by
my suggestions so there was a stoicism
class like a fully fledged fully
dedicated stoicism class and in my
college experiments and and the reason
the reason why this stoicism class
existed according to the instructor was
was because of of her being interested
and the different attempts to help the
university that I was putting out there
and she said that she wanted to see if
how many people would join who would be
interested in it
what sort of progress would be would be
made through it so in this in this class
I I suggested so I lost I lost my train
of thought because the reason why I lost
my train of thought is because I had
this there was this little voice in the
back of my head that's saying don't say
something unless you'd unless you mean
it
unless you're actually nuts and that's
been a very helpful kind of backup or
you just attempted to say something no
actually no but it was it was kind of
like a it's every tedious recommendation
of your own enemy like and away because
it in my when I was starting to discuss
the stoicism class I thought it myself
are you it's just an opportunity to glow
is that is that what you're trying to do
and I know that I'm not yeah great but
in in reference to this this stoicism
class I could not tell you I lost my
train of thought it's gone well so I was
curious how many people took the class
about twenty that's really good
for a college class yes so the the way
that it was phrased or handled was that
we we were expected to take course or
take sections of paragraphs and parts of
books and try to
apply it so you are going to do kind of
what I suggested before which was take
paragraphs and try to apply them and
then kind of communicate and small teams
what what we kind of accomplished so
there were different concerns
understandably that were that were
brought up or different ways of
approaching the the class that that
differed so for for me personally I
partnered up with my roommate my
roommate attended the class because
because I was attending there were
others that were considered themselves
to be persons that enjoyed philosophy
generally but didn't knew that I was so
I can wanted to be a part of the class
and wanted to kind of like see what kind
of holes they could they could create
and in stoic philosophy last week people
are good for that yeah so they kind of
the the idea they enjoyed classes the
most where the general premise was how
do we know that there aren't little
orange monsters chasing us around we
just don't have to see them that that
sort of thing so a lot of their
arguments in their essays was that so a
system was only for rich people who are
in a position to say to themselves I
don't need any kind of external things
because they already have it like Seneca
yeah right yeah
arguably yeah at which the
counter-argument was and is still while
epictetus was one of the strongest
advocates and he yeah he literally came
from nothing and you know CLE anthias
yes you know school are the stoic school
the guy who I mean he got he got the job
that the other there were other people
who could have been the second school
art but he was the one who was
practicing it the best was you know
passed it on to him and he was a water
carrier yeah that was about as low as
you can get
he was also at one point he was so well
respected or well regarded that he was
offered some kind of like big financial
gift yeah um to him but I think that
xeno rate or was it whoever it is that
was tutoring him said you're absolutely
aren't gonna take that yeah
you just be kept doing uh what what he
was doing it was said that he was so
thrifty that he could have supported and
Epictetus brings us up that he could
have supported to clean these on his
meager income from carrying water all
around yeah well we should we should
wrap this up because I don't want a
rubber battery so the the the site is is
it applying stoicism calm yes okay so
that's the main that's the main website
that has compilations of all of my
writings that's where all of my essays
go has PDF links to everything that a
friend resources yes a main resource
list that I'm trying to expand all the
time yeah so I asked the authors of
these different resources for their
permission to add them to the site and
once I received that then they get
posted on there and they're ordered
alphabetically you should put this video
on the site - yeah well and then there's
the Facebook group really great sit to
check out there's a Google+ group for
those who are anti Facebook you're not
on Twitter are you I am oh no I couldn't
yeah I couldn't fit I think it's 15
characters ah so it was it was one
character short so again and I had to
just come to terms with it and say it
wasn't gonna be able to get applying
underscore saucisson yeah or applying
stoicism in there so it's apply
underscore stoicism so the ones enough
yes right so the the main focus or tent
behind the Twitter side of things is
experimental so to speak where I would
post quotes that are small enough oh
yeah right
yes it's extremely tough and so there's
less of that now because there's only so
many self-contained quotes yeah because
it's all all contextual for the most
part but now what it what it is
it's a newsfeed to an extent
occasionally I will post updates on
there new things that have popped up on
the website I will still post smallish
quotes on there when I can make it
happen or personal thought that I've had
that can happen to be encapsulated in
140 characters so it's not really a
resource is more
in itself it's more resource that that
points towards other resources well for
people who like Twitter there they're
used to that that sort of thing yeah
he's also on patreon which is a
crowdfunding so I'm a backer of Travis
because I believe in the project so I
encourage you to you know if you think
it's worthwhile make a monthly pledge
because that way you're helping him to
be self-sufficient everybody's got an
earning income one of my goals that I'm
keeping very my expectations are very
carefully managed is eventually I'd like
to write full-time on on stoic
philosophy because of that missing 99% I
have taken it upon myself internally to
try to develop my understanding of
what's already out there to the extent
that I would be able to help recover
some that 99% which is very
controversial statement aware that but
that's that's how I feel that's what
they're trying to do yeah any last words
you wanna say just thank you for
watching I hope that you were benefited
from it and if you check out my
resources that you're benefitted by
those too
thanks for for coming up and Tran is a
good personal friend of mine too so you
know happy to do this interview with him
yeah but here at stoic on almost o
account is over that's what allowed us
the opportunity to actually be in the
same place at the same time you know
that's I think we only see each other we
Skype but I think we only see each other
face to face at Starcom well yeah we
kind of done like a V type shape or like
where we're meeting and of in Canada at
this location that's reading in Canada
yeah so all right so we'll end on that
again check out the links below and yeah
that's pretty much it
yep everybody
you